after biggie spends almost 20 minutes
wearing the harness Caesar leads
everyone outside for the next step what
we want to see is that she's comfortable
with the harness even in this side of
your house let's go for work what we're
trying to do here is for her to move
with the harness on yes before we put
her on the car okay yeah there you go oh
that's very good and that's really the
motion we want in the card what she puts
us herself with the back leg that's
right it's all making sense now we're
gonna do it a little bit more difficult
for her
so she tells you right away when that
thing is around this is how I feel I
know that look yes I felt like I'm in
the way a job and so I'll do anything
you know whatever I could do to enable
her to you know be freer walk so I got
the heck out of there John is a good
example today of a man who was not
afraid to show weakness yes he had a
little trouble in the beginning but then
he said you know what I'm doing this for
binky I fine so we're asking her to get
close to the object now the object if
you get closer you get food then you
place her in there just for a little
while okay
so right now she's doing exactly what
you say normally when we put this thing
on this is what she's right
if she takes one we'll remove the object
not taking it sometimes what happens is
they don't want that same scent that's
what you have to bring at the difference
in case you don't give her lettuce so
she likes Tomatoes all right this to me
too she she wants this she likes us meat
seem to be full
I feel like Benihana
chop-chop there you go so that we remove
the object and reward
oh and that's delicious so what she's
really getting is that object gives her
food yes it's it's so making sense yes
so that's the mean she's gonna go into a
walk right away
Caesar switches places with Sylvie so he
can use her affection as binky's reward
for getting hooked up to the device legs
here watch this so
there you go so and say there you go see
it
he's a how I set her up to go in there
but then I remove her bring it back okay
so she was facing this way and I keep
moving her moving her until she find no
choice just to go in there this right
way yeah okay
and then she faced the right way I let
her relax a little bit then I remove her
it so I answer with so they're gonna ask
you so what you want I want you to go in
there and so what you're gonna get me
after that then after you relax I took
you away you give and take it's not such
a thing you just give give give and not
take there you go that's good you see it
that is good see so you become the carry
the banana and all that stuff see I mean
I always have to use food and the person
who's you know helping here that
intensifies the relaxation about being
in there so now we're we're conditioned
in the brain that is she goes in there
she receives affection another positive
experience
I'll do it for you okay this is teamwork
by the way okay sir mark is good see
where it's great she's standing up on
her hind legs she's never done it was
she's not a Raider I know it was the
best you've done yes
not here here here here what are you
doing Reverend
you